- So it's like Cruella
De Vil minus the R and
then Lenny like Lenny Kravtiz and you put
them together and it makes Kuella Lenny.
- Cruella Lenny?
- Sure.
(upbeat pop music)
- Is that the name on
your birth certificate?
- Where are you from?
- But where are your parents from?
- Is that your real name?
- What does that mean?
- My first name is Kuella Lenny.
- Can you spell that for me?
- K as in kindergarten
and U as in umbrella and
W as in a whale.
It's easier if I sing it to people.
- Okay.
[Kuella Singing] Kuella Lenny
- I'm calling to put in a reservation for
two for Friday night.
The name for the reservation?
You can just put it under the letter K.
- That's a hard name to pronounce.
- Wow, your name is so unique!
- That must've been a hard name as a kid.
- Do you have a nickname?
- Thank you for meeting with me, this
was really great.
- Of course, yeah, so
it was Kuella Lennaay?
- No extra accent, just Kuella Lenny
- Oh, I got it, I got it, Kuella Llllenny.
- It's actually super easy,
it's just Kuella Lenny.
- That's a mouthful, I'll
never be able to say that.
My weekend was filled with Tchaikovsky, a
little Schwarzenegger, and Game of Thrones
marathon because I love those Targaryens.
- You don't look like I thought you would.
- Whoa, didn't think you'd be a woman.
- I didn't think you'd be American.
- You're new right? I'm Ryan.
- Oh hi, I'm Amro.
- Amir?
- No, Amro.
- Army?
- Am ro.
- Omar?
- Yeah, sure.
- Cool, nice meeting you
Happy birthday Omar
- Are you Chloe?
- Yeah, what's your name?
- Kuella Lenny
- Oh, cool!
- What's your name?
- Kuella Lenny!
(muffled noises)
- Kinda hard to say, it's Kuella Lenny.
- Kuella Lenny, wow
that's a beautiful name.
- Thank you.